[Musique]
développé par RTE le l'entreprise qui
est le réseau de distribution de
l'électricité pour échoa je ne sais pas
ce que ça sera mais en tout cas ça sera
une référence qui permettra comme
Ecowatt l'a permis aux Français pendant
la période où en s'inquiétait sur
l'approvisionnement en énergie et bien
de d'avoir les gestes du quotidien qui
vont permettre de faire la différence
sur les économies d'eau les syndicats
pourront-ils parler de la réforme des
retraites et même des 64 ans à Matignon
mercredi j'imagine qu'ils en parleront
je crois que à ce stade il faut à la
fois respecter nos institutions la
démocratie parlementaire s'est exprimée
le texte est désormais entre les mains
du Conseil constitutionnel ce qui
n'empêche pas de poursuivre le dialogue
social c'est la raison pour laquelle la
première ministre a convié les syndicats
qui évoqueront sans doute la question
des retraites mais la question très liée
et qui n'a évidemment pas été
intégralement traité dans le projet de
réforme des retraites qui est celle du
travail sur lequel nous avons bien
l'intention d'avancer rendre le travail
supportable pour que 64 ans finalement
ça soit acceptable rendre le travail
supportable tout court parce que nous
avons de toute évidence et ça s'est
exprimé dans les cortèges que nous avons
vu et qui ont été paisibles en tout cas
pour ceux qui étaient pour l'essentiel
de ceux qui étaient mené par les
responsables syndicaux je salue
d'ailleurs l'attitude de Laurent Berger
qui a aucun moment on a dénigrer le
processus de démocratie parlementaire
qui a conduit à l'adoption de la réforme
cette question du travail était au cœur
des attentes et elle est au cœur des
attentes et des inquiétudes des Français
il faut lui apporter des réponses et
c'est bien notre intention alors
beaucoup de sujets dans votre domaine
notamment l'intelligence artificielle
une pétition à l'initiative des lones
musk rassemble de très nombreux
signatures d'experts internationaux ils
disent attention les garde-fous éthiques
vont moins vite que les progrès de
l'intelligence artificielle il faut une
pause soutenez-vous cette initiative les
pétitionnaires posent une bonne question
mais ils apportent une mauvaise réponse
la question est bonne parce que
l'intelligence artificielle si elle est
porteuse de d'immenses à commencer par
l'accélération du progrès scientifique
la une détection précoce de maladies
comme le cancer la découverte de
traitement ou de vaccins comme celui
contre contre la covid elle porte aussi
sa Parton donc les questions méritent
d'être posées la réponse est mauvaise
parce qu'il ne s'agit pas de faire un
moratoire ou d'arrêter le progrès de la
de la science c'est d'une part
impossible ce n'est pas ça n'est pas
réalisable mais en plus ça n'est pas
souhaitable mais en revanche la version
5 6 7 de chat GPT ou d'autres non il est
préférable d'agir comme nous l'avons
fait en européen en créant un cadre pour
l'intelligence artificielle avec un
règlement qui est en actuellement
discuter au niveau européen qui
s'appelle le règlement sur
l'intelligence artificielle dans lequel
nous disons voici les activités pour
lesquelles l'intelligence artificielle
est interdite exemple la surveillance
des généralisée des populations voici
les activités pour lesquelles
l'intelligence artificielle est permise
mais soumise à des obligations de
transparence et à des audits pour le
sport pour la santé pour les
applications qui vont permettre aux
entreprises de recruter ce sont des
applications qui sont critiques qui
peuvent poser des questions qui peuvent
créer des risques sur la sécurité des
personnes pour le transport et la santé
les risques de discrimination dans ces
cas-là et bien l'activité est encadrée
et puis il y a des des activités pour
lesquelles l'usage de l'intelligence
artificielle est libre voilà
l'architecture du de la manière dont
l'Europe compte que l'Europe compte
doter plutôt que de mettre un coup d'art
au progrès de la science premier fait
divers tragique rapporte les médias un
homme dépressif ce serait suicidé en
Belgique après avoir demandé de l'aide
après avoir conversé avec un logiciel
interactif de ce type là est-ce que ça
ça vous inquiète
ça nous inquiète évidemment et c'est la
raison pour laquelle il y a quelques
semaines j'ai saisi le Comité national
pour l'éthique du numérique c'est un
comité qui a été créé en 2019 qui a été
placé auprès du Comité national
d'éthique du professeur Jean-François
desprezi précisément pour réfléchir à
ces questions à ces questions qui qui
relèvent de l'éthique et de choix
démocratique en l'occurrence la question
qui est posée est celle de la D du
risque de déshumanisation qui accompagne
le développement de ces modèles avec une
insuffisante perception par les
utilisateurs de la nature d'automates de
ces solutions comme ça a été le cas et
en fait c'est une machine évidemment et
ça ça pose une question majeure qui
mérite une discussion et qui va mais qui
va susciter des discussions et un débat
public à mon avis approfondi les
versions de ces logiciels vont très très
vite on est loin du perroquet
approximatif que vous aviez décrié dans
un premier temps ça n'était en aucun le
cas une critique c'était une description
de ce que sont ces modèles de ce qu'il
s'a fait de ce qu'ils ne savent pas
faire les modèles tels que tchat j'ai
pété les modèles d'openhague vont à
partir de masse de données très
considérable en réalité les les données
de l'Internet en réponse à une question
faire la moyenne des contenus qu'ils ont
trouvé et la restituer en l'état c'est
donc une forme de restitution
stochastique de de de contenu trouver
sur internet que réalisent ces
algorithmes alors comme je l'ai dit tout
à l'heure ça n'est ni plus ni moins et
c'est les chercheurs qui les ont
intitulés comme ça avec un perroquet
stochastique ce qui ce qui n'est pas
très loin du perroquet approximatif que
j'ai dit avec ces grandes promesses pour
l'humanité et ça par nombre qu'il nous
faut traiter et ce qu'il ne faudrait pas
une convention citoyenne sur
l'intelligence artificielle que les
citoyens réfléchissent sur leur liberté
par rapport à tout cela
peut-être aurons-nous peut-être c'est
une idée que à laquelle je je veux bien
réfléchir il fallait au préalable avoir
une réflexion éthique de la même manière
que le Comité national d'éthique a remis
un avis qui a servi et bien de fondement
aux discussions réflexion sur la
convention citoyenne sur la fin de vie
et bien j'ai saisi il y a quelques
semaines le Comité national d'éthique
pour l'éthique du numérique qui va nous
rendre un avis au mois de juin et qui
sera le point de départ de de je dirais
de la réflexion démocratique et
d'éventuellement une loi
nous verrons si la loi s'impose comme je
l'ai dit nous avons un cadre européen
qui est en cours de constitution s'il
faut le prolonger par des lois inspirées
par cet avis inspirés par le débat
démocratique alors rien n'est à exclu
comme vous avez légiférer sur les
influenceurs dans une un climat
d'uneanimité d'ailleurs à l'Assemblée
absolument je crois que nos concitoyens
attendent de nous que nous puissions
sécuriser réguler l'espace numérique
dans lequel il trouve beaucoup de
d'opportunités nouvelles de
communication d'échanges de découverte
mais dont ils ont bien conscience qu'ils
présentent à certains nombre de risques
qui sont insuffisamment maîtrisés Bruno
Le Maire a souhaité se saisir du sujet
des influenceurs il y en a 150 000 en
France avec des activités qui vont de la
découverte scientifique au conseil en
cuisine etc en passant par tout un tas
d'autres
exactement et donc il fallait à la fois
créer un statut pour ces influenceurs
qui est un métier nouveau et puis
protéger les consommateurs et interdire
certaines activités dont chacun avait
bien ambition que elle conduisait
peut-être à tromper sur la marchandise
ces derniers jours j'ai noté une
cyberattaque contre la mairie de Lille
une contre le Conseil départemental du
Gard une contre l'Assemblée nationale
qui sont derrière ces attaques est-ce
que vous le savez détruant ou des trolls
russes il faut le dire il y a un
business de la cyberata que qui se
développe et c'est ainsi que ces
derniers mois on a vu de grandes
collectivités des hôpitaux dans ma ville
de Versailles en particulier
des départements des régions des grandes
villes se faire attaquer et face à ça il
faut adopter les gestes barrières une
hygiène numérique et ça nous appartient
puisque ces attaques comme vous le savez
elles commencent par des maladresses
humaines c'est en captant nos données
personnelles que les pirates parviennent
à entrer dans les systèmes de ces
grandes organisations combien de
millions de milliards chaque année en
rançon payer
c'est pas un chiffre dont je dispose
c'est pas d'ailleurs un chiffre que je
communiquerai si je le si je l'avais de
manière consolider ce qui est sûr c'est
que nous nous faisons d'une part tout en
sorte pour ne pas avoir à payer ses
rançons et la meilleure manière de ne
pas les payer c'est de faire de la
prévention d'éviter c'est avant
l'hôpital de Versailles vient de
retrouver 4 mois après le début de
l'attaque son activité normale il faut
tout faire pour éviter que ces attaques
se déclenchent sinon elles peuvent avoir
des conséquences sur le long terme tout
faire ça peut être aussi par exemple
dans les hôpitaux revenir au dossier
papier
revenir au dossier papier c'est une
situation c'est une une solution
d'urgence à laquelle l'hôpital de
Corbeil-Essonnes l'hôpital de Versailles
ont été contraintes il faut pas
dénumériser les activités
administratives ou je ne crois pas parce
que les la numérisation du dossier du
patient par exemple et tu t'engages de
meilleur accompagnement du patient il
faut en revanche le sécuriser et ce que
nous voulons faire pour prévenir ces
attaques entre autre chose c'est
notamment conformément à l'engagement du
président de la République pendant la
campagne créé un filtre anti-arnac de
manière à ce que tous ces SMS que chacun
d'entre nous reçoit pour aller voir son
compte personnel de formation sont
contaminés pour aller payer les impôts
qui sont des faux SMS et convocation à
nous envoyer sur des sites qui
collectent nos données personnelles de
nos données bancaires nous allons créer
un filtre qui viendra s'interposer et
vous avertir que vous êtes en train de
vous diriger vers un site malveillant
pour éviter la Constitution par les
pirates de base de données personnelles
qui permettent ensuite à d'autres
pirates auxquels ils auront vendu ses
listes et bien de s'infiltrer dans des
organisations la France après d'autres a
interdit Tik Tok et à ses fonctionnaires
est-ce que le président Macron en
parlera en Chine la semaine prochaine
le président de la République a beaucoup
de sujets à évoquer avec la Chine qui
est un partenaire commercial important
pour la France et pour l'Europe mais
s'agissant de l'espace numérique et des
données personnelles nous avons une
approche qui est différente de celle de
la Chine et nous comptons comme nous
l'avons fait en européen l'année
dernière avec des règlements très
importants qui ont été adoptés faire
respecter nos principes et en
particulier le respect de la vie privée
c'est la raison pour laquelle la semaine
dernière avec Stanislas Guérini nous
avons annoncé un régime
d'interdiction générale sur les
téléphones les smartphones fournis par
l'État à ces agents de téléchargement
d'applications récréatives telles que
Tik Tok mais tel qu'aussi que Facebook
ou d'autres il y a une commission
d'enquête au Sénat sur TikTok ça
pourrait aboutir à une interdiction pour
tous les citoyens français on banni
TikTok de la France à nouveau je suis
pas sûr que le bannissement la même
manière que le moratoire évoquait tout à
l'heure soit la soit la bonne solution
je crois que ce qu'il ce qu'il convient
de faire c'est de faire respecter
les principes auxquels nous sommes
attachés la commission d'enquête est une
très bonne nouvelle et sénateurs sont à
pieds d'oeuvre pour traiter à la fois
des questions de respect de la vie
privée et de protection des données
personnelles mais aussi de l'impact que
tic-tac Tic-Toc peut avoir sur notre
jeunesse qui et ce sont les jeunes qui
le disent et bien souvent beaucoup trop
entraîner dans des phénomènes
d'addiction du fait de l'algorithme de
Tik Tok Jean-Noël barreau merci bonne
journée merci beaucoup Christophe et on
peut annoncer d'ores et déjà votre
invité de lundi matin ce sera haute-man
Nasro vice-présidente
l'actualité très bien Marylise Léon pour
la CFDT et bien voilà vous le faites en
direct aussi bien que moi